um sie ranken sich viele ungelöste
geheimnisse uranus und neptun sie sind
die äußersten planeten des sonnensystems
ein forschungsteam hat jetzt
herausgefunden dass es auf dem blauen
gasriesen tatsächlich diamanten regnet
team von astro comics tv ich erklären
euch in diesem kind wie es dazu kommt
fix und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nicht herzlich
willkommen uranus und neptun werden auch
die eisriesen genannt das liegt
allerdings nicht daran dass es dort
gefrorenes wasser gebe die beiden
planeten bestehen aus dem gas und zwar
größtenteils aus polen und wasserstoff
wenn man kohlenstoff in ausreichendem
maße verdichtet erhält man genau ein
diamant der verdacht lag also schon
lange nahe dass es auf den eisriesen
wertvolle edelsteine regnet den beweis
dafür konnten wissenschaftler vom
helmholtz-zentrum in dresden durch ein
aufwendiges laborexperiment erbringen
die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen aus dresden haben
die extremen bedingungen auf uranus und
neptun im labor nachgebildet dafür
verwendeten sie einen kunststoff namens
polystyrol der aus wasserstoff und
kohlenstoff atomen aufgebaut ist also
genau wie die eisriesen durch künstliche
schockwellen eines röntgenlasers wurde
in dem kunststoff eindruck von 1,5
millionen bar und eine temperatur von
5000 grad celsius erzeugt als die
forscher den kunststoff diesen extremen
bedingungen aussetzten beobachteten sie
wie sich kohlenstoffatome zu diamant
strukturen zusammensetzen der dresdner
forscher dominik klaus beschreibt den
prozess so die erste kleinere und
langsamere schockwelle wird dabei von
der stärkeren zweiten überholt in dem
moment in dem sich die beiden wellen
überschneiden bilden sich die meisten
diamanten
genau dies geschieht auf uranus neptun
in den riesigen gas schichten der
planeten bilden sich beständig kleine
diamanten die nach und nach in das
planeten innere sehen es ist allerdings
nicht damit zu rechnen dass die beiden
äußeren planeten auf absehbare zeit
komplett zu diamanten werden denn das
absinken der diamanten aus der
atmosphäre dauert tausende jahre die
erzeugung von diamanten durch röntgen
leser hat auch praktischen nutzen hier
auf der erde diamanten werden immer mehr
in der elektronik als leiter verwendet
sie speichern strom und wärme wesentlich
besser als herkömmliche materialien
durch unsere erkenntnisse von uranus und
neptun können wir also auch die irdische
technologie verbessern ein gutes
beispiel dafür wie astronomische
erkenntnisse uns auch tatsächlich weiter
bringen und zwar hier auf der erde auch
die forschung auf unserem roten nachbar
planeten mars lassen gutes erahnen man
kann dort tatsächlich kartoffeln
anpflanzen um mehr darüber zu erfahren
klickt auf dieses video
die antwort ist tatsächlich verblüffend
also anklicken anschauen und dem kanal
astro comics tv abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran